all right meow come your way first
because i was reading the press notes
and i was shocked when they referred to
this as your first leading role because
i feel like i've seen you stand out in
so much at this point so i guess first
what was your reaction to booking the
part because when i read that my first
reaction was like it's about down time
yeah i was really excited um to find out
that i that i booked this uh to this
role
you know but that excitement doesn't
last very long and and and that's
quickly replaced by just a lot of
anticipation and anxiety to to hope that
you know i i i'm able to to do
thai and the film and the rest of my
cast justice be because you know it was
a lot to take on with maxine and and and
pearl and you know you should playing um
a girl from uh from the south you know
it just couldn't really be this is very
far away from who from who i am
uh but yeah it was uh
i i definitely welcomed the challenge
and and it was something that i wanted
to do and so i was very excited to to be
a part of it
job very well done it paid off big time
one more question for you now uh what is
something that you picked up from a
number one on the call sheet on a
previous film that you found really
coming in handy when you were the lead
on x your behavior your work ethic you
the the way that you
uh
you know relate to the crew and how you
treat everyone around you it really does
have a trickle-down effect and yeah i
have seen that in other instances where
i've worked with you know you know
actors that i really look up to and
they've always treated the cast and the
crew really well and and um it pays off
and it just creates a better environment
everyone's happier and and and and
ultimately um the work is better off for
it
could not agree more i always appreciate
hearing that
all right brittany unless i am missing
something it has been a very long time
since you've done a horror movie so
why the wait and then when you got onto
the set of x was there anything that
made you say like wow i really missed
that part of making a horror movie yes
you're not wrong it's been 10 years uh i
did would you rather when i was 25 um
i just gave away my age why would i do
that um sorry uh but i i
i love doing horror movies because i
think that there's a intricacy there of
um
making something suspenseful but layered
and you are just having a blast because
it's so
it's it's escapism to its finest right
it's it's so
um over the top in terms of like what
you get to do and as a human being you
get to tap into places that you're
hopefully never going to go through and
so um it really expands your imagination
in in a new way and so i i really i love
it i i missed it
would you rather it's so damn good i
rewatched that movie too often it's such
a great concept oh thank you yeah
all right jenna so you have the opposite
thing where you've done a lot of horror
back to back to back and if i have my
dates right i believe you filmed this
before scream so was there anything that
you experienced or learned while making
x that you found coming in handy on that
movie no i actually i booked x while i
was on screen so it was like i actually
i got the call from ty while i was with
matt and tyler so they all shared hellos
and also kind of caught up
because they used to work together in
the past which was kind of funny
but if i were to flip the script and if
i were to say oh if there's anything
that i learned on screen that i think i
think for me i don't know if there was
anything that i learned in particular
because the characters are so different
but i think just like
having
very freshly ran for my life and
screamed at the top of my lungs and done
whatever it was just it felt like second
nature it wasn't something that i was
worried about coming on and
it felt very familiar i didn't feel
too out of place
let's put up the spoiler warning now so
we could talk about a couple things a
little more freely and
jenna can you tell me about filming the
conversation when lorraine announces to
the group that she wants to be in
farmer's daughter because it's a pretty
drastic shift for the characters so i
guess
what was the key to making that choice
feel true to her rather than just being
necessary to push the plot forward in a
certain direction
well what i love about the script is
it's not known that it's true to her
because she is playing off of the horror
film conservative christian girl
stereotype so i think what you see from
her especially because she's church
mouse and she's pretty quiet
and just kind of stares as maxine puts
it
for me it was just kind of uh a way to
surprise the audience but then also add
another layer to her that it wasn't
really seen because i think
the first half of the film she comes off
it comes off as very um judgmental and
self-righteous and she almost seems like
she feels like she's too good to be
there or just doesn't want to be there
um
when i think once we finally have that
conversation we learn that it's just an
unfamiliarity with the subject and also
curiosity that she never really knows
how to correctly phrase it and it kind
of seems like this entire time she's
just kind of been working up to this
moment um i also it's it's a really
important scene because it's right
before everything kind of goes wrong
so i think it's not only a turning point
for her but then also just the the
storyline and what's to unfold and
um it's a it's a good reminder of the
audience that like i don't know kind of
expect the unexpected and um
i was really excited to show that part
of lorraine because i i do think that um
she's actually a pretty open-minded
um individual and that's not something
you would typically um think of somebody
during that time period in a horror film
very very powerful scene there and it's
perfectly placed in the film uh the
movie didn't necessarily
need this but when i get very into
something i tend to want to know every
single backstory detail about a
character me i was wondering if you ever
did any backstory work on pearl to
determine when you know the first
incident happened that sparked that kind
of violent behavior in her what brought
that out in in in addition to just you
know the longing of wanting to achieve
her original dream
yeah ty and i discussed pearl's
backstory um a lot
uh
and and that's something that i really
enjoyed um
with my time with tai was that actually
we uh
you know i'd never been so involved in
in in with my prep with a director in
the past where we
like we spoke
you know for a good couple of hours
daily before we ever met for the first
two months
and it was like that in in
pre-production during production and
even to this point i mean it's just been
um the most uh
creative collaboration that i've ever um
had the chance to to experience and uh
and and i really think that that
it helped it helped it helped the work a
lot well congratulations this one's been
weighing on my mind ever since i saw it
it's fantastic and enjoy south by
southwest
you